[Music]
what do you do when you're a we'll call
it an adult
entertainment provider and the adult
entertainment industry is being turned
upside down by this thing called the
internet with this free tube and hub
sets filled with all your illegally
pirated scenes
what do you do when you go from making
north of five thousand dollars per scene
or sixty thousand dollars per month if
you just do three scenes a week
to a plebian 200 to maybe a thousand
dollars a scene where to even make a
measly thirty thousand dollars a year
you'd have to start in a hundred films
as a female or 150 films as a male
which by any metric is a lot of scenes
to perform
what do you do i'll tell you what you do
you turn to escorting selling your time
your company to others and whatever else
happens during that purchase time
happens between two consulting adults
you know what i'm saying yes i know what
you were saying you don't have to keep
asking
maybe now you have to deal with another
middleman called a pimp
this is so stupid maybe now you have to
deal with another middleman called a
pimp
what or maybe you turn to webcaming
which became a thing later on
whatever route you choose you're
probably only making a tiny fraction of
what the industry used to pay but then a
platform called onlyfence became a thing
which turned the industry completely
upside down cutting out almost all the
middlemen and putting the profits back
into the hands of these adult
entertainment providers
before the pandemic hit only fans had
less than 20 million users
afterwards 120 million sims i mean
consumers
with more than 300 creators earning more
than a million dollars on the platform
this is the booming genius nutty
economics of only fans
a truly disruptive platform that merged
the creator economy with the adult
entertainment economy
and in this video we're going to try not
to get demonetized subscribe if you want
more risque business video essays like
this
shout out to sammy for submitting this
video idea and winning 500
stick to the end to learn how you can
win 500 or more as well
let's get into it
[Music]
if you're going to become an only fans
millionaire or any kind of millionaire
you're going to need a place to put all
those sweet stacks of cash you're gonna
be making
that is where extra comes in forbes
favorite smart wallet in today's video
sponsor
guys i've been using this wallet for
over a year now and i absolutely love it
i'm never
going back i've never gotten so many
compliments on a single accessory
before it's ridiculous you just whip it
out you feel the high quality gold with
the leather and then you pull the
trigger and feel and hear that
satisfying movement and sound
and you have instant access to all your
cards and you look super
fancy and elegant while doing it it's
got a removable cash strap to hold extra
cards and cash if you need it like i
have right now and if you don't need it
it's even thinner it's got an optional
gps tracker in the back it's rfid
protected to protect your hard-earned
money from all those skimmers out there
exeter was the second brand to ever
sponsor this channel so they hold a very
close place in my heart for believing in
me and i am very pumped that they're
back these also make for the perfect
gift i've given three of these away to
my friends and they all love it
because nothing says i believe in you
more than giving them a wallet from the
store all the fat stacks of cash they're
gonna make it
i personally love the senate model i
have right here in black leather because
what other color would i get but they
also have an aluminum version if that's
more of your style and some very clean
colors they also have a parliament
version which has even more storage but
i think that's a little bit too bulky i
think this is a good medium go to
extra.com slash j train and use the
coupon code jake tran to get five
percent off on top of any site-wide
promotion they have going on at checkout
that's exeter.com jaytran with the
coupon code jtran with the link below
in the late 90s and early 2000s the
adult entertainment industry was
centered in san fernando valley which is
north of la
and it was extremely lucrative like we
mentioned earlier upwards of over five
thousand dollars per scene
as a star you could even supplement that
income with nightclub appearances across
the country on the weekends if you
wanted to
the stars were making money the
producers and directors were making
money because they had control over the
distribution of the content
but as napster stole the profits away
from the music industry youtube light
sites also started stealing profits away
from the adult entertainment studios
the only difference between the music
and adult entertainment industry was
that the music industry had the money
and power to sue their pirates mostly
out of existence
the adult entertainment industry the
nuts so the rates for scenes collapsed
fewer scenes were shot
and studio started selling their content
to tube sites for pennies on a dollar
the napsters of the adult entertainment
industry won by 2015 a few companies
controlled most of the markets
just like how a few tech giants control
most of today's social media sites
with the biggest conglomerate being mind
geek who owns most of the tube sites you
all know and love
adult entertainment stars turn the
escorting and webcaming as we mentioned
earlier but then in 2011
a website called customs for you was
launched where as a consumer you could
become your own director
ordering specially made videos from your
favorite stars this would be the
precursor to only fans
and then instagram took off the founder
of customs4u had a lightbulb moment and
only fans was born
[Music]
instagram along with youtube did
something special that the world had
never seen before
it allowed average everyday people to
create a personal connection with their
followers
to the point where you kind of feel like
you're virtual friends with your
favorite youtubers and instagram
influencers
you know what they're like as a person
at least on camera you know what they
like what they don't like just like a
real relationship
but the problem was there wasn't an easy
way for instagram influencers to
monetize their content
so only fans was created as a natural
boat onto instagram's free feed as a
subscription only feed
creators can set a monthly price of five
to fifty dollars you can have a free
teaser page where you can charge up to
fifty dollars for pay-per-view content
and fans can give you up to a hundred
dollar tips
with only fans taking only twenty
percent of their earnings which
according to only fans comes out to
around only twelve percent after fees
but that still begs the question why
would someone want to pay something like
fifty dollars a month when they can
easily view as much
entertainment as they want online for
free because if you understand that
you have the potential to join this new
social class of only fans millionaires
[Music]
when seeing the act itself has devolved
into a commodity that anyone can open an
incognito tab right now to view for free
online
you have to address other pain points
than just seeing the act itself
if you want to make money wink wink and
the way you can think about this is if
standard youtubers and instagram
influencers are kind of like your
virtual friends
then you can think of only fans models
as kind of like your virtual girlfriends
only fanstar and danny harwood put it
best you can get for free guys don't
want to pay for that
they want the opportunity to get to know
somebody that they've seen in a magazine
or on social media
i'm like their online girlfriend
[Music]
and she has the numbers to back it up
way back in august 2018
she was already making over 29 thousand
dollars a month
then over 34 dollars in september then
over fifty two thousand dollars in
october then nearly fifty three thousand
dollars a month in november
one can only imagine the number she's
pulling in now after the pandemic boom
the sims i mean guys on only fans aren't
looking for hardcore entertainment or
else they would have went elsewhere for
free
no they're buying the feeling of being
loved connected cared for in certain
ways by a star they adore online
now this may sound pathetic because it
kind of is but think about it the desire
to feel love connected care for no
matter if the person providing those
feelings means it or not
is the stuff of the human condition
every man longs for that experience heck
a man is willing to up and his entire
life sacrifice everything for a woman he
loves
so when looking at it through this
perspective 50 a month doesn't seem like
that bad of a deal
in fact this primal need for intimacy is
surpassed only by our need for food
shelter and the dirty act itself
[Music]
you know it used to be that to get the
girlfriend experience to experience
intimacy you'd have to put yourself out
there winner girl over pay for an
in-person experience that cost a lot of
money but now with the internet only
fans have to remove
all that friction so sims can go
straight to the source and that's what i
believe to be the true genius of only
vans
because if you look at all the giant
internet companies of the recent years
all they really do is remove friction
facebook removes the friction of staying
connected with friends and family
uber and lyft remove the friction of
travel google removed the friction of
digging for information
tinder and bubble remove the friction of
dating friendship travel mating
these are very primal fundamental needs
humans have always needed to do since
the beginning of time
they just made it easier more
frictionless than before and therefore
became massive successes
that same logic applies for the recent
success of clubhouse going from zero to
a billion dollars in less than 12 months
we've always needed to have
conversations around the campfire
they just made it more frictionless only
fans followed in the same footsteps
except instead of removing the friction
of staying connected traveling
conversations
it removed the friction of intimacy and
made it on demand
that is the real business only fans is
in intimacy
which is probably why by november 2020
only fans brought in 281 million pounds
or nearly 400 million dollars in revenue
to put that into perspective if only
fans went public today
it would probably be a deca unicorn or a
company that's worth over 10 billion
dollars
making it one of the uk's leading tech
companies
[Music]
one of only fan's goals today is to move
away from just adult entertainment by
attracting other kinds of content
creators
beyonce name dropped only fans in a
recent song and right after the site saw
a reported 15
spike in traffic to promote her song wep
cardi b
included an only fan's page with behind
the scenes content michael b jordan who
was in black panther started and only
fans to raise money for a barber school
vice starter not only fans for his food
channel munchies but time will tell if
this catches on with other mainstream
influencers versus something like
patreon though
now i know what you guys are thinking
but jake we're dying for you to make an
only fans where are you gonna make one
so i can sign up
that's so sweet of you guys and you're
in luck because i just did
onlyfans.com jaketran but before you get
too excited i'm literally not going to
post anything and if i ever do
it's definitely not going to be nudes so
do not subscribe but definitely
subscribe to this channel
[Music]
now that you know that the business
model and economics of only fans is all
about selling intimacy
it is time to pick up a beautiful
functional
extra wallet to hold all that only fans
cash you're gonna be making
again i've been using mine for over a
year every single day and i've tried a
lot of minimalist wallets out there and
this one is still my favorite and just
the impression
it gives people is well worth every
single penny in my opinion you can pick
one up for yourself
or for that special someone to show them
that you believe in their financial
success
with the link below expert.com jake tran
and use coupon code jake tran to get
five percent off at checkout link below
congrats to sammy for winning 500
for submitting this video idea now his
idea and his face would be forever
cemented on this channel
if you want to be like sammy and win 500
or a thousand dollars if i use your
exact word for word thumbnail and title
idea
all you have to do is submit your video
idea with the link below and subscribe
to this channel you have to be
subscribed and
guys it took me like a good 30 minutes
to go over all the submissions from last
time which is awesome
but just try to aim for quality over
quantity really get the thumbnail and
title some thought before you hit submit
but that will be linked below
shout out to jolene for following me on
instagram every single week i will be
giving a shout to one of you guys that
follows me on instagram
jaytrend.io that is enough shameless
plugs for this video thank you so much
for watching you've been awesome i've
been jake stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
foreign